Boa noite a todos é um prazer est com
você aqui
novamente e eu quero um feedback de
vocês porque eu tô fazendo um setup
diferente eu aumentei a resolução do
stream para 1080 então a imagem deve est
mais nítida e nesse momento a câmera ela
tá Aliás o microfone que tá registrando
o áudio é do iPhone também que ele tá
acima do meu computador eu comprei um
suporte pro iPhone e tamb tá captando a
minha imagem e tá captando o meu áudio
então me dê por favor o feedback de como
está o áudio e como está o vídeo
ok enquanto eu espero vocês me darem o
feedback eu já vou começar respondendo
as dúvidas de
vocês doutora Ana não sei se ela vai
entrar hoje tá o Eliseu mandou um monte
de pergunta pra Ana mas a Ana ela não
tem obrigação entre aspas de entrar na
Live né vamos ver se ela entra hoje
não tenho essa informação o áudio está
ótimo obrigado Carlos e a imagem tá
melhor vocês acham que tá melhor em
relação à Live anterior porque a
resolução tá mais alta tá
tá bem deixa eu dividir a tela com vocês
aqui tirar esse esse Brand da frente
aqui né
esse aqui na verdade que tem que
mostrar bem deixa eu colocar aqui
a
apresentação Talvez seja melhor colocar
de colocar meu rosto
aqui ver qual que é o melhor jeito
aqui não é esse esse aqui é esse
mesmo bem deixa colocar o ulos aqui que
eu vou vou ver as perguntas é através do
compartilhamento
mesmo a imagem pouco nítida para mim a
imagem também está boa pouco nítida mas
aí não era para est menos né que 1880 né
Não entendi a escrita está ótima Que bom
vocês estão lendo bem né Se alguém não
tiver lendo bem depois você vocês por
favor me falam
tá primeira pergunta é do Eliseu na Live
passada fiquei sabendo que você gosta de
estudar os suplementos da Doctor first
Esse é o caso da Ana Paula não não meu
né você acha que os suplementos bitar de
colagen e o osto 2 Complex ambos da
doctors first é uma boa combinação para
col bem todos nós sabemos que o colágeno
é uma proteína fundamental pra saúde da
pele importante também para articulações
e ossos e que com passar do tempo a
produção natural de colágeno no corpo
vai diminuindo isso vai levar problemas
como perda de elasticidade da pele
fraqueza óssea problemas nas juntas
então tem basicamente dois tipos de
suplemento no mercado um que é de
colágeno geral e o colágeno hidrolizado
Tipo
dois então esse vitality colagen e o
osto 2 Complex doct first são
suplementos que são usados bastante para
manter a saúde óssea e também a
elasticidade da pele e pode ser uma boa
combinar os dois o Vital colagem aí Já
respondeu a segunda pergunta do Eliseu
que vai ser em sequência então vitar
colagen ele é um colágeno
hidrolizado ele é mais facilmente
absorvido e vai ajudar na elasticidade
da pele na saúde óssea já o óo do
Complex ele contém colágeno Tipo dois o
C2 né que a gente chama de uc2 ele é
mais específico paraa saúde das
articulações e dos Ossos ok
então a segunda pergunta que seria essa
aqui
ó já foi respondida
né óo do Complex é para articulações
porque é o C2 colágeno realizado tipo do
e o colágeno do Vital colagen é pra pele
Confere o suplemento creatina prime
micronizada da doctors first tem a
propagante ser muito Pura Sem corantes
artificiais
livre de soja e livre de glúten ser é
tão pura assim porque que a creatina do
Doctor first nunca aparece naquelas
pesquisas que fazem dos 10 suplementos
creatinas mais
puros Será que é porque a creatina da
doctors first não possui o selo
creapure então ele não tem esse selo
creapure mesmo
tá ele tem essa promessa de ser um
suplemento de alta pureza porém ele não
deve ter pago aí o royalty do creapure
Deve ser
isso a ausência do selo creapure não
quer dizer necessariamente que é ruim tá
significa que eles não estão usando
esse esse elemento né eles não têm esse
selo porque eles não devem pagar o
royalty não deve utilizar o creapure na
composição
então assim isso fica como uma dúvida
mesmo eu não ponho minha mão no fogo
pela pela empresa não D Ana Paula que
tem mais experiência com com essa
empresa
eh mas eu acredito que seja uma empresa
de boa qualidade
sim Tá então não é uma
prova necessariamente de que a creatina
da doctors first seria ruim tá mas então
é uma coisa que você tem que entrar em
contato diretamente com o fabricante Mas
eu acredito que pode ser alguma coisa
relacionada da
royalty próxima
pergunta quais podem ser as causas de
grande quantidade de cálculos biliares
em pessoa que nunca teve eh d seu
colesterol acima de
200 bem pessoal os cálculos biliares
eles são pedras na visícula eles são
depósitos endurecidos do fluido
digestivo que na vesícula biliar que
vocês sabem que é um órgão que fica
abaixo do fígado e que coleta o suco
biliar que produzido pelo fígado Então
os cálculos podem variar em tamanho
forma cor muitas vezes são
assintomáticos ou podem causar dor
intensa as causas dos cálculos biliares
mais comuns é alimentação rica em
gordura ruim carboidrato ruim dieta
pobre em
fibra o
sedentarismo dietas desculpa doenças
metabólicas como diabetes hipertensão
obesidade existe um a em medicina são os
quatro FS né o f de femil que é mulher
fet de de obeso Por que seria mulheres
na Facha de 40 anos e o quarto F agora
não me lembro mas é muito comum em
mulheres obesas que tiver acho que o é o
4f de filho é muito comum em mulheres
obesas na faixa dos 40 anos que tiveram
filhos então ise é um fator de risco
importante para pedra no na vesícula a
alguns remédios podem aumentar o risco
de perna vesícula uso prolongado de
anticoncepcionais terapia também com
estrógenos né vi oral pode aumentar o
risco existe uma predisposição genética
a história familiar de cálculos biliares
pode aumentar o risco de desenvolver
essa condição elevados níveis de
estrogênio que não sejam necessariamente
reposição também pode aumentar o risco
de formação de cálculos biliares Ok
então então esses são os fatores de
risco mais comuns
eh antigamente aor first enviava o l do
suplemento mas agora não envia mais is
significa que o suplemento doctors first
não é confiável não
necessariamente essa mudança de política
você deve ter essa resposta porque que
Eles mudaram com com o próprio
fabricante E se a gente for falar de de
reputação desculpa reputação da empresa
a reputação é grande de acordo com as
avaliações disponíveis em plataformas
como reclame aqui e no trust Box a
doctor first tem uma nota média alta e
resolve 100% das reclamações recebidas
Então tem um índice alto de satisfação
com os
clientes então o trust Vox que é um site
especializado
em OB ter informação se os reviews são
verdadeiros ele atesta que sim são
verdadeiros e são feitos por clientes
reais tá então isso aí eh não quer dizer
necessariamente que não é confiável Mas
seria bom você entrar em contato com a
empresa para obter mais
informações o suplemento pumpkin pro da
doctors first possui PS 1 g de óleo de
abóbora 10 mg de vitamina e diz o site
que é bom para reverter a próstata
aumentada e também para fortalecer o
cabelo Isso é
verdade bem ele tem o extrato da Semente
de abóbora que é rico em vitamina E
então Eh por ter o óleo de abóbora ele
vai ter Beta coster que é um composto
antiinflamatório que pode ser benéfico
para o equilíbrio
hormonal nós sabemos que a vitamina E é
conhecida por suas propriedades
antioxidantes então eu não usaria só
isso paraa próstata tá o óleo de semente
de abóbora é muito bom por causa dessa
questão do Beta coster que é um composto
natural antiinflamatório que ajuda a
evitar a bexiga hiperativa ele vai
evitar a contração involuntária da
bexiga mas tem que associar com outros
ativos para ter um efeito mais intenso
também vai ajudar no cabelo ajudar a
fortalecer o cabelo porque o óleo de
abóbora tem essas propriedades
inflamatórias antioxidantes que vão
ajudar a promover a saúde do
cabelo lógico vai variar de pessoa para
pessoa o s Doctor first sugere que o
suplemento Hair Boost também Deva ser
utilizado pro cabelo então você pode até
combinar o óo de semente de abóbora o
pumpkin pro com Hair
Boost
Ok ão Respondendo a sua dúvida aí pode
ser utilizado os dois suplementos
juntos na Live passada foi recomendado o
site da
Boss encontrou o texto que o o pode ser
utilizado de um 100 microg por 1 ml O
ozônio medicinal
certo aí ele pergunta a dose no caso
Eliseu a dose 100 microgramas deve ser a
melhor dose que tem não vou responder
que não tá a mais potente não não é
que quanto mais melhor não não funciona
assim
Eliseu tá e não é você que pede a dose
pro médico ele que vai definir Através
de outros critérios tá aí eu vou dividir
até com vocês aqui para explicar
visualmente essa questão da concentração
de ozônio então eu vou ter que trocar a
tela aqui pera
aí não não é
[Música]
vof ué tá toop screen tem que colocar
outra tela aqui
deixa eu achar aqui onde tá aqui essa
imagem
aqui então vocês estão vendo aí né Tá
vendo que tem a dose Anes celulite que é
bem baixinha 2 MG antirruga 5 microg
lipolítico 10 antiflogístico e
antálgicas
inflamação e a dor essa faixa mais
utilizada em torno de 20 MG tá
25 um pouquinho mais vai ter Mação um
pouquinho mais antiinflamatória 30 vai
ser imunoestimulante 33 antiacne 40
bactericida 50 virucida 60 fungicida 70
imunos supressivo 90 esclerosante É
muito raro você usar dose de 100 essa
dose imuno esclerosante Ok então é muito
difícil alguém usar a dose de 100 Eu
particularmente nunca vi utilizar e tem
pouquíssimas aplicações
Ok vamos voltar pra tela das
perguntas Existe algum suplemento ou
fitoterápico que pode ser utilizado no
lugar das estatinas tem vários
tá você pode usar ômega3 em casos bem
leves você pode usar também em casos
leves O alho fitoesterois são esterois
que são tirados de plantas você pode
usar alguns tipos de fibras o que eu
gosto de usar e também que é substituto
direto da estatina é o Red East Rice que
é o arroz de levedura vermelha para
aumento HD colesterol você pode usar o
ex nicotinato inositol você pode usar
pantetina você pode usar os tocotrienois
extraídos do Urucum né que é o natural
Max então tem várias opções aí para para
substituir estatinas tem também o Vas
gard que é um extrato Vas gard que é um
extrato da
Bergamota todos esses você pode utilizar
as lugar das
estatinas bicarbonato sód é útil para
evitar a infecção urinária
recorrente Então existe alguns sites que
falam que o bicarbonato sódio seria
interessante para evitar infecção
urinária mas para mim não faz o menor
sentido isso porque geralmente quando a
evita a infecção a gente acidifica a
urina com vitamina C então O bicarbonato
faz o contrário alcaliniza a urina então
a alcalinização da urina é útil Em
algumas situações por exemplo se você
forma cálculo de ácido
úrico aí você quer alcalinizar a urina
sim para não formar a pedra de ácido
úrico Ok essa é uma situação porque
algumas pessoas têm infecção na área de
repetição devido à formação de pedr de
cálculos Então essa é a única situação
que eu recomendo daria alcalinizar a
urina com bicarbonato para evitar de
maneira secundária né ou indireta a
infecção urinária através da inibição da
formação de cristais de ácido
úrico Ok Ficou claro isso daí se não
ficou pode perguntar ao
vivo Qual que é o melhor óleo essencial
para micose de unha tomil orégano Ambos
são bons tá eu Us os dois juntos mas foi
para escolher um
só eu utilizaria o tomillo porque ele é
rico em timol então ele é um pouquinho
mais potente do que o
orégano mas eu usaria a Associação dos
dois
OK outra coisa você pode utilizar também
a melaleuca também tem ação
antifúngica o cravo também tem ação
antifúngica e você pode associar a
lavanda também ok
lembrando sempre que os óleos essenciais
tem que ser diluídos tá em óleo de coco
em óleo de amêndoa outros óleos vegetais
para evitar reações alérgicas Eles são
muito potentes tem que ser diluídos em
outros
óleos eu tenho vídeo sobre isso no canal
para vocês
assistirem geralmente na maioria dos
casos deção é uma
gota perdão 20 gotas do óleo para 9 ml
do óleo vegetal que pode ser óleo de pco
óleo de amêndoa óleo de uva ou óleo de
rosa mosqueta
Ok considerando que a vitamina B1 ajuda
no processamento de carboidratos uma
suplementação pode dar um empurrãozinho
na melhora da Resistência sínica se sim
em torno de 1,6 MG ao dia ou mais sim a
vitamina B1 que a tiamina ela é
importante metabolismo dos carboidratos
na geração de energia do corpo então
você pode usar ela sim para ajudar mas
ela não é um um suplemento muito útil
para combater a diretamente a resistên
insulínica mas vai ajudar sim como
secundário OK agora como primário eu
usaria
berberina que é mais potente mas tem
outros suplementos também você pode
utilizar agora tem a forma de tiamina e
a f de benfo
tiamina a dose mas vamos falar primiro
da tiamina a dose a recomendação pode
ser bem variada tá já vi desde 1,2 MG
até mais de 100 mg por dia então se você
for usar uma dose baixa pode fazer com
conta própria Se você for usar uma dose
alta você tem que fazer
com acompanhamento
médico Ok então é bem variável a dose
tem até protocolo para parkson que usa
doses assim de gramas tá 2 g 3 G por
dia então é um suplemento muito seguro
dificilmente vai te intoxicar Mas se
você tiver usando sozinho use na faixa
de massa 2 MG por dia e com o médico
acompanhando pode aumentar esta dose
agora se você tiver diabetes já
instituído a benfotiamina vai ser mais
eficaz é uma faun Amina sintética porém
ela tem apesar de ser sintética ela tem
a maior
biodisponibilidade e tem a ação de
proteger os nervos tá tiamina é muito
interessante para evitar a neuropatia
diabética ela vai reduzir também a
formação de produtos de glicação
avançada que podem afetar retina rins e
coração atletas também usam a befu
tiamina para aumentar o desempenho
aeróbico e pode ser utilizar também
paciente de alsheimer
aamina aqui tem uma pergunta tá falando
das doses de bor Cromo manganês
se o que subiu aqui pera
aí perguntando as doses de Bora Cromo
manganês lítio tá isso aqui vai vai dar
de pessoa para pessoa pessoal não dá
para responder isso aqui isso aqui tem
que ser feito acompanhamento dos níveis
no sangue para ter uma
ideia melhor tá o boro a faixa que você
vai
repor Então essas faixas que você
colocou é exatamente literatura é a
faixa normal É de 0,01 a
0,1 do Boro do Cromo de 0,05 a
né e isso vai dependente de pessoa para
pessoa vai variar de pessoa para pessoa
essa suplementação
tá manganês sérico normal é até
1,6 e o tóxico é acima de
5,4
Ok o lítio também é muito variável
também tá o nível terapêutico para
pessoas que TM transtorno bipolar é de
0,6 a
1,2 tá então não tem assim essa eh sua
dúvida de níveis médios isso vai variar
de pessoa para pessoa e tem vários aí
que não tem um consenso na literatura
mesmo
tá tinha três nódulos de tireo RS 4
desde maço doía muito mas depois o
meloxican inchou um pouco o volume
passou a dor porém ainda sema muito
cansaço praque e dor no corpo o médico
queria arrancar tireode sem fazer
biópsia outra médico passou isso aqui
aqui é caso Clínico gente não é para
passar caso Clínico específico para
para esse tipo de de meio aqui né da
Live e outramente que aação meloxican
bloqueador pro prolol pois os nódulos
pareciam excretar muito hormônio
causando híper perdi toda a qualidade de
vida ma consigo sair ao Maracas e
trabalhar
Já tomei duas goas de lugol por dia
melhorou mas depois de uns três dias
piorou tudo de novo não faça uso de
lugol sem acompanhamento médico 30% das
pessoas que estão lug dá problema agora
estou tomando sua fula par ndulos mas
sintomas horríveis de um provável hiper
continua Tem mais algum remédio se você
tá com hipertiroidismo tem primiro que
ver os exames se tá com hipertiroidismo
mesmo se tiver ter que tom tapazol
tá não dá para te responder isso aqui
isso aqui é culta médica não é uma
pergunta apropriada para pro grupo de
apoiadores Você pode agendar uma
consulta comigo ou com qualquer outro
médico trabalha com a medicina
integrativa funcional tá não dá para te
responder aqui mais que tem Boa Vontade
primeiro que a chance de eu errar é
muito alta porque eu não conheço seu
caso todo segundo que o isso não é o o
canal correto para responder isso tá a
dica que eu te dou é faça exam de
tireoide de laboratório de sangue veja
se você tá com Peti dismo mesmo se tiver
vai ter que tomar tapazol E se for uma
doença autoimune vai ter que tomar nação
de baixa dosagem
também o tirat 4 ele tem um risco
moderado de ser maligno tá então tem que
fazer biópsia sim ok mais lá Ribeiro
fala que câncer tiroide não não mata
ninguém próxima
pergunta Doutor Ah não tem mais aqui
eh tem conhecimento se é possível o
homem que repõe a testosterona
bioidêntica ter alterações de
comportamento para agressividade sim é
possível o vou apresentar tomada de
decisões incompatíveis sim se tiver
muito agressivo com excesso de
testosterona pode tá por exemplo
decisões que contrariem a lógica
provavelmente a reposição de testosteron
nessa pessoa tá exagerada a dose tá
muito alta Doutor alguém que tenha
sofrido um ait a fazer da fala pode
eventualmente como sequela apresentar
transtorno de comportamento PR
agressividade ou passar a apresentar
decisões ilógicas sim é possível
é possível
sim eu volto nesse assunto daqui a pouco
tá boa noite Carlos Eloí Jade
Carlos Eliseu Denise Manuel
ah J fo você que mandou a a pergunta
aqui
do dos nódulos né eu não posso fazera
médica por aqui Jad você deve ser novo
no no grupo
né
Olha acho você que fez a pergunta do
nódulo vou olhar aqui pera aí
isso foi você tinha feito Jad não eu não
posso trabalhar exame seu
aqui por esse meil viu Jad por mais que
eu tenha Boa
Vontade pelo seu TS parece tá com hitio
dismo você vai ter que tomar na axona de
baixa dosagem e tapasol tá mas eu não
vou mais falar mais nada além disso
porque isso não é o meio para isso Jad
isso aqui não é um lugar para fazer
consulta médica informal isso aqui é
para tirar dúvida de medicina não para
fazer consulta médica tá me entenda por
favor tá
bem vamos paraa próxima aqui
Ah sim eu ia dar mais detalhes aí da
questão da fazia da
fala então como eu falei é totalmente
possível uma fazia em decorrência de um
AVC provocar transtorno de comportamento
que inclui agressividade decisões
ilógicas tá
isso pode acontecer em lesões cerebrais
que atingem áreas como lobo frontal
porque o lobo frontal é responsável por
m funções como julgamento planejamento e
controle
emocional além da agressividade os
pacientes que têm lesão do lobo frontal
podem ter habilidade emocional depressão
ansiedade mudança de personalidade
é importante fazer o quê o uso de
medicamentos né para controlar os
sintomas
psiquiátricos Talvez um canabidiol
estaria bem aí né um full
Spectrum além de lifestyle né estilo de
vida atividades físicas regulares
prática de
mindfulness Terapias cognitiv
comportamentais
tá então essa era a última pergunta da
Ita
bem eu tenho alguns assuntos para falar
para vocês
aqui primeira coisa que queria falar
participei lá do congresso médicos pela
vida confesso a vocês que em alguns
momentos foi maçante para mim porque me
pareceu que eles colocaram um excesso de
palestrantes para falar não sei para
agradar todo mundo e foi bastante
redundante algumas coisas né eles
falaram
de alguns
aspectos várias vezes de maneiras
diferentes então palestrante a falava
uma coisa muito parecida com palestrante
B mas um ponto de vista um pouco
diferente então isso foi maçante para
mim eu fui lá pessoalmente no sábado
fiquei até 5 horas da tarde e domingo eu
não fui
eh e assisti algumas palestras da
sexta-feira então eu tô separando aos
poucos alguns materiais aqui para
discutir com vocês trazer o resumo o que
é importante vocês saberem tá vai ficar
disponível online para mim durante algum
tempo essas palestras então aos
pouquinhos eu vou discutindo então o
primeiro assunto que eu quero discutir
com
vocês é sobre o uso de máscaras
tá eu não vou usar o o o nome da doença
tá aquela doença de 2020 eu vou chamar
de moléstia e toda vez que eu vou falar
disso aqui ó eu vou chamar de terapia
higiênica
Ok deixa eu abrir aqui o
artigo sobre tem vários aqui tá eu tô
separando vários materiais para vocês eu
vou falar primeiro das
máscaras tem a tenho que achar agora
aqui
o material que eu separei sobre máscaras
pera aí não tá aqui não pera aí tem que
achar isso aqui pera
aí aqui
achei tá
então teve uma palestra de uma médica de
Indiana que é a Dra Michele
schner não sei se pronuncia o nome dela
ela expôs o
material no congresso e
uma das questões que mais interessou as
pessoas de modo geral que foi um grande
símbolo né daquele período de 2020 foi o
uso de máscaras né devido à moléstia
Então por décadas já se sabia né que
máscaras segundo a doutora não impede a
disseminação de vírus respiratório e é
muito simples vocês entenderem isso né a
malha da máscara especialmente as
máscaras caseiras que foram utilizadas
aí por 99% das pessoas ela não permite
bloquear uma uma parte partícula tão
pequena quanto um vírus Então essa
Doutora fez uma pesquisa muito
abrangente na literatura sobre uso de
máscaras e ela não tem conflito de
interesse para se expressar chegou a
várias conclusões
as três perguntas que ela entende que
precisam ser respondidas são as máscaras
interrompem a propagação da moléstia ou
de outros vírus respiratórios primeira
pergunta elas não seguras segunda
pergunta terceira Deveríamos ser
obrigados a usá-las então o primeiro
ponto importante entender o tamanho de
um vírus uma partícula do vírus da
moléstia tem
0,125 micrm muito muito pequeno o vírus
da gripe ainda menor tem de 0,08 A 0,12
micrm então para comparar um fio de
cabelo humano tem 150
micrm ou seja ele é vezes maior o fio de
cabelo do que uma partícula do vírus da
moléstia então para impedir que essa
partícula passe com uma máscara seria
necessário uma máscara
muito específica muito tecnológica que
teria que ter um filtro Epa tá
heep tá esse filtro Epa esse filtro
especial ele retém de 99 a 100% das
partículas
virais tá mas para usar uma máscara com
filtro Epa teria que utilizar inclusive
de corpo inteiro tá como se fosse uma
roupa
espacial máscaras cirúrgicas só filtram
partículas acima de 100 micrm que não
foi a máscara que a maioria das pessoas
utilizou tá então o vírus da moléstia é
1 vezes menor do que a capacidade de
filtragem dessas máscaras já a N95 que
era a máscara top a gente tinha acesso
para compra
ela bloqueia cerca de 95% das partículas
com 0,3 micrômetros
ainda assim isso é três vezes maior do
que o vírus da moléstia Então nem a
N95 nem a máscara cirúrgica consegue
impedir a passagem dessa partícula
viral Então as máscaras cirúrgicas como
as utilizadas em salas de centro
operatório funcionam como Barreiras não
como filtros
então para a barreira contra a secreção
mas não um filtro Ok então para filtrar
um vírus seria necessário um filtro Epa
como eu falei para
vocês a segunda pergunta impede a
propagação do vírus da moléstia então
utilizando dado CDC o Dr gura comparou
49 estados dos Estados Unidos com e sem
mandatos de uso de máscaras e não
encontrou associação entre os estados
onde exigia a o uso da máscara tinha o
mandato e a redução de casos teve
estudos em criança também na Espanha na
Finlândia nos Estados Unidos também não
encontraram correlação entre o uso de
máscaras e a taxa
de
molesta o exemplo mais claro é o da
Suécia onde as escolas permaneceram
abertas durante toda a pandemia sem
distanciamento social então na Suécia
eles não tiveram aquele recolhimento das
Crianças tá não houve essa exigência de
usar testes né de exames né ou mandatos
de máscaras e não houve
mortes pela moléstia em 1,8 milhão de
crianças nos Estados Unidos CDC analizou
90.000 crianças em escolas da Geórgia
comparou escolas com 100 mandatos de
máscara também não encontrou diferenças
estatisticamente
significativas porém dois meses depois o
CDC e a academia americana de Pediatria
ignoraram os seus próprios dados e
recomendaram o uso Universal das
máscaras nas
escolas Por que que as máscaras não
funcionam contra vírus
respiratórios já falamos do tamanho da
partícula né dá mais informações aqui
isso ocorre porque esses vírus se
espalham por aerossóis pequenas
partículas que permanecem no ar e
escapam pelos espaços nas máscaras
cirúrgicas inclusive na N95 então quando
a máscara fica úmida pela respiração que
é muito comum então você não vai ficar
julgando fora a máscara a cada 2 horas
né ninguém faz isso ainda mais N95 que é
cara a eficácia então pela esta umidade
vai diminuir ainda
mais Mesmo durante a implementação dos
mandatos de máscaras não se evitou a
segunda onda da moléstia o que mostra
que elas não são eficazes na prevenção
da propagação do vírus AL al disso uso
de máscaras que aí seria a última
pergunta poderia ser
prejudicial então o Ben insira analisou
35 países
europeus 602 milhões de pessoas
encontrando uma correlação positiva
entre o uso de
máscaras infecções e mortes pela
moléstia ou seja na visão do benir
analisando esses dados 35 países de
vários milhões de pessoas centenas de
milhões de pessoas ele percebeu na visão
dele que o uso da masc estava aumentando
os casos Ok não diminuindo o zakar fagan
também analisou dados do Canas e
descobriu que os Condados com mandados
de máscaras apresentaram uma taxa de
mortalidade significativamente maior ele
chamou isso de efeito fagan onde
inalação profunda de gotículas virais
presas na máscara Ou seja a própria
Máscara tava segurando as gotículas lá e
fazendo a pessoa respirar de volta a
gotícula além disso em poucos minutos é
possível cultivar bactérias e fungos
patogênicos das máscaras isso levou ao
aumento de pneumonias bacterianas E
meningites então a médica que palestrou
em sua experiência como neurocirurgiã
pediátrica observou um aumento dramático
de abcessos intracranianos e crianças
que usavam as máscaras e diariamente
estudos mostraram que quanto mais tempo
se usa uma máscara mais crescem colônias
de fungos uma pesquisa na Califórnia
mostrou que até 3 milhões de colônias
bacterianas foram encontradas nas
máscaras de alguns passageiros de
trem a máscara também pode causar
aumento dos níveis de dióxido de carbono
inalado um estudo italiano mediu níveis
de CO2 sob máscaras após 10 minutos de
uso encontrou valores acima do limite
aceitável de 5000 partes por milhão
especialmente em
crianças outro problema das máscaras são
os microplásticos e compostos orgânicos
voláteis que tem nessas máscaras que
podem ser inalados e isso aumenta o
risco de doenças pulmonares
inflamatórias e fibrosas Então teve um
estudo britânico que detectou
microplásticos nos pulmões humanos
provenientes das máscaras que podem
causar doenças
pulmonares então esses são os principais
problemas das máscaras não impedem a
propagação do vírus da
moléstia podem criar ambientes propícios
para o crescimento de bactérias e fungos
dificultam a respiração eficaz
aumentando o CO2 resultando também na
inalação de microplásticos e outros
compostos
tóxicos e também essa Doutora na sua
palestra alertou que o uso prolongado de
máscaras também tem Impacto
Desenvolvimento Infantil teve um estudo
que mostrou uma queda de 30% na fluência
de leitura em crianças de segundo e
terceiro ano nos Estados Unidos e outra
pesquisa indicou uma queda do QI médio
de crianças nascidas durante o período
né de 2020 com impactos
negativos no desenvolvimento verbal
motor e cognitivo a saúde mental também
foi afetada com estudos relatando
aumento de ansiedade dificuldade
respiratória deformidade faciais devido
à respiração bucal em crianças o uso
diário de máscara levou que foi chamado
de síndrome de exaustão induzido por
máscara no desenvolvimento da primeira
infância outro estudo foi realizado pela
Rad Island Hospital da Brown University
eles analisaram 700 crianças usando as
escalas mullen de aprendizado precoce
então eles compararam as crianças
nascidas em 2020 e 2021 o a 2011 2019
aliás 2020 e 2021 com Anas que nasceram
entre 2011 a
2019 então ele Descobriram que o q médio
caiu de 100 para 78 e houve uma queda
significativa nas pontuações verbais
motoras e cognitivas Gerais os homens
eram mais baixos e os homens que saíram
pior em termos
socioeconômicos e as Crianças foram as
mais
afetadas Então quais foram os fatores
que contribuíram mais para esse declínio
foi a interação social que foi reduzida
tá pelo fato dos Pais estavam em casa
mas não estavam disponíveis para
interagir com as
crianças e as crianças pequenas os bebês
eh estavam com dificuldade de receber o
feedback adequado dos Pais elas não
conseguiam ver as expressões faciais O
que é fundamental no desenvolvimento
para aprender a avaliar as e feedback
isso estava levando a interações
robóticas sem
emoção e é muito importante também
observar que a boca dos pais quando eles
falam ela tem que ser vista pelas
crianças importante para desenvolvimento
motor e psicológico das crianças é assim
que elas desenvolvem a
fala se você olhar para um bebê de 8
meses como é que ele se comporta ele
fica olhando pro rosto da pessoa que tá
falando especialmente paraa boca quando
você
fala então teve também estudos que
mostraram que prejudicou a saúde mental
que as máscaras exacerbaram a ansiedade
as dificuldades respiratórias o ataqu de
pânicos aumentaram e a claustrofobia
também
certo então é isso pessoal então uma
aula sobre máscara espero que vocês
tenham gostado do conteúdo
aqui e a máscara
pff3 n99 que diz filtrar
99% Boa pergunta primeiro que essa
máscara deve ser bem cara segundo você
teria que trocar essa máscara a cada Du
horas para ela continuar sendo eficiente
porque eu expliquei que a umidade na
máscara vai tirando eficiência dela tá
então o a apresentação da doutora que eu
acabei de reproduzir aqui para vocês ela
não falou especificamente sobre esse
modelo tá ela falou do N95 doa Filter
Mas eu posso dizer para vocês que não
deve ser tão melhor assim do que o N95
que como eu disse para vocês a Trama
dela ainda é três vezes maior que o
vírus em detrimento de tantas queimadas
no Brasil e nosso ar insalubre a máscara
eh ela não vai bloquear fumaça queimada
não viu J Só se você usar uma máscara
que para Filter que seria o máximo do
máximo do máximo que praticamente você
tem que usar aquela roupa de
astronauta Mas você se você se sente
segura com a máscara J pode usar só
fique ciente de que ela aumenta o gás
carbônico é um dos problemas da máscara
você vai aspirar mais gás carbônico
e não vai te proteger da maneira como
você tá imaginando Tá mas eu respeito
totalmente aí a visão de quem acha que a
máscara é interessante eu escutei de
pacientes durante o a pandemia que eles
estavam achando que a máscara Tava
ajudando a evitar infecção respiratória
tava evitando gripe e por aí vai então
algumas pessoas me comentaram isso acho
que foram mais menos umas 15 eu não
acredito nisso e os dados que eu tô
vendo dessa palestra contradizem isso
mas totalmente quem eh quer usar máscara
Inclusive eu vejo ainda algumas pessoas
na rua usando máscara el sentem segura
com isso então eu acho que tem que ser
visto caso a caso eu não recomendaria
para a maioria das
pessoas Eliseu eu não vejo nenhum
problema de aplicar no mesmo dia não
não eliz eu acho que isso não confere
não eu vou dar uma
checada mas eu acho que não confere tá
sua formaa para nó de tiroide tem iodo e
iodeto se tiver hipertiroidismo pode
tomar
depende vou ter que rever essa fórmula
mas eu acho que tem lá é é é iodo kelp
né eu tem que abrir esse documento de
novo e vê lá mas não tome no gol tá que
é iodo com iodeto sem acompanhamento
médico tá Jade
Olha a informação que eu tô tendo aqui
viu eliz que o consumo de ldn não
interfere na quantidade de potássio no
corpo nem um azul de metileno tá
então e na verdade tem que ver se você
não tem dess graves tá porque pelo TS
suprimido Você pode ter doença de grve
não doença de rimoto que é outra doença
autoimune menos
comum Ah não sei Eliseu não sei se tem
todos os benefícios do estilo orgânic do
morango orgânico não tá Dá uma olhada lá
no
rótulo Denise Eu já respondi isso aqui
você volta no vídeo não é recomendado
bicarbonato de modo geral para evitar
infecção urinária não eu expliquei Isso
é só você voltar o
vídeo só em caso pessoas que T cálculo
de ácido úrico aí O bicarbonato tá sendo
usado para evitar a formação de de ácido
úrico que poderia secundariamente causar
infecção urinária mas de modo geral não
use bicarbonato para isso para evitar
infecção
urinária Boa noite Estela tudo bem com
você
querida não não tem dificuldade de
direção nem Ejaculação não
Eliseu depende Eliseu você tem que
testar geralmente não é excesso não mas
para algumas pessoas mais sensíveis Pode
ser sim são sorrisos sim elizu
Que bom que você
gostou bem pessoal que já tá bom
né era uma pergunta desse vídeo mesmo
sobre a dose bicarbonato então Eh você
escutou errado o quê que eu falei ou não
entendi Denise tá de modo geral eu não
recomendo usar o bicarbonato para
infecção naárea de repetição tá só como
eu expliquei pessoas que têm facilidade
com uma cálculo de
astur Só que os cálculos de ácido úrico
puro são raros tá é menos de 10% dos
casos
Ok bem pessoal Muito obrigado pela
participação de vocês na
Live eu peço a vocês para convidar a
amigos
parentes pessoas dos seus contatos aí
para entrar no grupo fechado tá eu tô me
esforçando aqui para melhorar cada vez
mais você estão vendo que tô criando o
índice das lives tô criando até
conseguir arrumar uma ferramenta para me
ajudar a colocar o link pro ponto do
vídeo específico onde eu falo de um
assunto então a gente tá sofisticando
bastante aqui a a questão das lives né o
o próprio Professor luí Antônio Peixoto
que tem uma idade eh muito maior que a
minha não tem essas benesses todas de
você ter essa facilidade de ter os
resumos das lives de você ter o ponto
exato dos vídeos de onde a Live tá se
vocês forem nas nas lives mais antigas
agora tem eu tô progressivamente
colocando isso você pode clicar ali na
no primeiro comentário fixado você vai
ter lá os os links para cada ponto do
vídeo do que tá sendo falado
tá então eu peço para vocês para para
prestigiar aqui o grupo fechado para as
pessoas que T interesse em saúde natural
saúde integrativa saúde funcional para
você convidar as pessoas a conhecer o
trabalho e se inscreverem como membros
do canal tá bom lá no
YouTube não sei Eliseu nunca nunca li
respeito de aterramento aumentar sonho
não sim artemisia ajuda a combater o
câncer sim artemisia tem propriedades
anticâncer
bem pessoal grande abraço até a semana
que vem